Brett Favre is linked to conspiracy to
misspend over 70 million dollars in
welfare funds in Mississippi the
nation's poorest state of that more than
70 million roughly 8.1 million have been
alleged to finance projects tied to far
these include a 5 million volleyball
facility at the NFL Stars alma mater
Southern Mississippi where his daughter
also played volleyball at the time
earlier this month text messages from
2017 between farv and non-profit
operator Nancy new seemed to indicate
that former Mississippi Governor Phil
Bryant was aware of the plan another 1.1
million allegedly went directly to far
for public speaking appearances in 2017
and 2018. parents says that he never
showed up for two million dollars is
also alleged to have gone to
pharmaceutical startup for which Barb
has been an investor John Davis the
former head of Mississippi's Department
of Human Resources LED guilty this week
to conspiracies to commit fraud and
theft with charges that could carry a
maximum of 15 years in prison as early
as September farv has been questioned by
the FBI at this time he has not been
charged for the crime investigation
since the alleged fraud are ongoing